Syria says Israel has hit its territory
with air strikes as well State media
says Israel targeted two Army posts in
the province of Dera that led to quote
some material losses Israel's Army said
it was responding to missile launches
from Syria targeting its territory
Israel also says a group of Fighters
armed with anti-tank missiles from
Lebanon were struck by its forces near
Northern Israel well let's go to
Southern Lebanon where we can speak to
our correspondent Zena Hoda in Ramesh
and Zena talk us through of the changing
tactics that you're seeing there in
fighting across the
border yes we're now in week four of the
confrontation along lebanon's border
with Israel between hasbalah and the
Israeli military there is a change in
the trajectory of this conflict a change
in tactics and that was really clear to
us yesterday on on Sunday first of all
Hezbollah using a new weapon the ground
to surface missile that targeted what it
said was an Israeli drone and according
to Hezbollah it was a successful hit so
hasbalah saying or showing that it has
new weapons to use more advanced weapons
to use we also saw the targeting of a
settlement now when we say an Israeli
settlement what we mean is a population
Center across the border in Israel even
though towns and Villages along the
border have been evacuated you can hear
the sound of constant shelling behind me
so this of course what we saw the first
3 weeks was the the rockets that were
launched from Southern Lebanon into
Northern Israel were targeting military
positions So Yesterday a residential
building inside uh inside a settlement
and then what else did we see Rockets
longer range rockets that are being
fired from South Lebanon into Northern
Israel hitting deeper into Israeli
territory Israel's response uh hitting
deeper into Lebanese territory so it's
no longer geographically confined to the
two to three depths uh um you know on
both sides of the border so that is
slowly expanding and we are also seeing
hasbalah using new tactics because at
the end of the day we saw it it really
suffered quite a number of losses nearly
50 men in the first three weeks is quite
a high number since Friday they've
reported the death of two men now how is
this conflict going to evolve we may get
a clearer picture on Friday when
hasbalah Secretary General Hassan n
gives a televised address it will be his
first public address since this conflict
began but we have to remember this is a
secretive organization that does not
reveal and put all its cards on the
table so we may get an idea how much
more involved Hezbollah intends to be in
this in this war and Zena talk us
through the shelling that we're hearing
about by Israel inside
Syria well yes uh the Israeli military
reporting that mortars were fired from
Syria falling in the goolan Heights a
Syrian territory occupied by Israel
Israel responding by targeting Syrian
Army infrastructure even the Syrian
State television the state media is
saying that Army posts were targeted now
it is highly unlikely that this is the
Syrian military firing those rockets in
the past Israel has blamed uh armed
groups allied with Iran for those rocket
attacks and really Israel has been
striking Iranian uh linked positions in
Syria for years now so this clearly is a
message from from the Israeli military
that the regime could be targeted the
already fragile regime in Syria could
face a retaliatory strikes if more
Rockets are fired across that border
putting more pressure on on on on Israel
okay Zod bringing us the situation there
on the border between Lebanon and Israel
thanks very much Z